[Music]
and rapping priest news of no submitted
by daddy David a Catholic Church is that
the summer fun to meet somebody else a
Catholic Church that's how I feel same
way okay a Catholic Church in Kenya has
suspended a priest we're using rap music
to spread the gospel Wow
why what did they use cardi B song
that's the best way to retain
information
you can't praise with me if you voted to
oh it was like a remake with a with the
hip-hop beat I'll show you a video oh I
thought he actually got like a song like
a cover it's like some dope-ass
Christian rappers but there's something
really really bad ones too
no not not a song cover like like
actually a song that exists and he
played it in the church no he was using
hip-hop beats to spread the gospel yeah
okay it's really a rap song there's a
group called gospel gangsters but like a
mainstream I know they have there are
mainstream but Kanye had a song that was
I says what I got show me the winner cuz
I don't know they were trying to take me
down that was very good hahaha you know
what the West is in Restless keep going
you know what the Mae West which is
younger Restless no David knows longer I
know I love Allah Kanye West
I love expectation x10 tachyon next 10
tokens
excellent guys alright P moving on so
this church it's called st. Monica
Catholic Church in southwest can't shake
Monica and never I don't know which st.
this is it's Catholic Church oh we got a
lot of things dude st. Monica Saint
Jennifer Saint Rachel
Thank You Monica always that was sent to
me st. Monica I don't know spinasse all
right that's what Santa Anna Anna yeah
Santa Claus it just sounds so odd to me
it's like st. Tyriq it's not a very
little a little officer but there is a
Santa Monica oh yes I'm and a Santa
Claus yes I Spanish sized it all right
so this father here this priest father
Oh God low that means jeonnam I'm gonna
show you a video clip of this priest
rapping usually what he does is he
doesn't sermon with the whole religious
get up
but then after he'll take off the
religious get up and then just wear
regular clothes and then I'll start
rapping but sometimes he'll wrap what
the religious get it
oh that's so much better than that that
bug in 1980s like Christian rappers [ __ ]
there my name is Jesus and I'm here to
stand believe it in me is the only way
God this it may be Grinch hated that
[ __ ] did yeah so apparently though the
Catholic Church does not approve of that
and so he was now suspended from he
didn't get a warning how do they
disapprove on the Pope DM them or
something oh that's not cool
[ __ ] I knew this was a bad idea
and that's why the Protestants and
everyone else split from the Catholic
Church so they can wrap so they can do
two hip-hop's it was tight and people
were loving it too yeah oh man you get
people walking towards Jesus with rap
what's the problem you get more clients
yeah yeah so apparently now the Catholic
Church said that he is free to worship
in the church but that he cannot lead
prayers in his previous capacity and so
like they're pretty much like suspending
him from brink being a priest for now so
he can review his methods I mean he can
go off on his own and like Joe said just
start his own thing oh yeah like what's
so hard about him doing it in his house
or just you know he already has his
people as for him when I was studying
music theory you guys know what
Gregorian chant is yeah
so they were saying that certain please
certain notes and stuff are the devil's
notes why you like it like wakes them up
yeah what happened those pop chords what
comes up with us I have no idea why or
whatever but it's just that I don't know
some yeah some [ __ ] keys and whatever
are sacred and for holy times what if
you're Asian and you only play The Black
Keys that's why we're always looked upon
as like mystical evil creatures and
[ __ ] movies and [ __ ] we're always the
[ __ ] bad guys the Yellow Peril it all
started from Bing Bing Bing demo it was
weird to even that Church there was this
one passage that came in I [ __ ] hated
Azusa cuts cuz he didn't make any sense
so we would play like Christian rocker
that's what the kids would like right
and it goes all the drums are for the
devil that's [ __ ] funny I really
should tell was like that's [ __ ] funny
because I remember specifically in the
Bible they would praise God with
trumpets and drums yeah it makes no
[ __ ] sense oh I don't know where that
logic came in so like he would just say
the devils were the drum no I mean the
the drums were the devil and also the
[ __ ] but specifically inscription they
would use that for pray so I didn't
understand what that man grandma said
that big guitar was a devil's weapon
yeah the [ __ ] devil Devils davil
devil comes out of that [ __ ] thing I
just do you know what I think it is I
think it's just dumbass old like Asian
people there's no like make up [ __ ] yeah
cuz they don't understand [ __ ] it's not
just like I feel like a lot of people
just make up [ __ ] and they use really I
just don't know dumb old Vaughn Asian
people cuz I don't hang up I grew up on
a [ __ ] the Asian Church and it's been
very consistent yeah they all make up
[ __ ] without [ __ ] knowing what it is
they just go oh you know what I don't
understand this [ __ ] I don't know what
it is so the easiest way to explain it
it's the mother [ __ ] devil you're
gonna go to hell if you do this yeah I
got in trouble at church for chewing gum
cuz it's the devil no wasn't cuz you
were going you're chewing big red that's
the devil's flavor shut up he likes like
his fingers in it no you made me spit it
out his hand dude good for him he like
was able to handle your spit in his hand
that's what I'm saying it's so weird I
was like you wanted you to let me chew
the gum bro my breath is kickin so back
to the rapping Chris here
is really sad that he can't leave these
prayers anymore like he's suspended from
being a priest and they're saying like
man the Catholic Church needs to get
with the times because you know this is
how he's relating to the young to youth
yeah they need new brainwashing tactics
all that [ __ ] is old man they need to
get with the [ __ ] times you need to
recruit and they're having a good time
why you got to be the one you know what
God never said hey be a party pooper
that's a [ __ ] Center to me you see
other people partying having a good time
celebrating the [ __ ] Lord and [ __ ]
and you go mm-hmm [ __ ] that no more
music
that to me the devil had been you know
part of a church community and so
[ __ ] long man I'd you know what I try
the most I try how often do you try at
least twice a month twice a month yeah
that's really good yeah so if I don't do
a church like physical Church I'll do it
like an online sermon yeah like it helps
out a lot helps me Center myself it's
almost like my [ __ ] a lot of wisdom in
that stuff but it's hard for me to find
like churches I like in LA because it's
there a lot they're very
business-oriented so like these smaller
traders don't really have that mentality
that's what I grew up in so like these
bigger churches these mega churches is
all about money they talk about tithing
every [ __ ] week if I make sure you
give 10% you check make sure you give
time I'm like what the [ __ ] is this like
I never grew up with that stuff yeah so
because I grew up in small churches
where I was just about family a family
got a family gun and that's all they
really cared about but these bigger
churches are a little bit odd too and I
think like sometimes I mean this is a
whole conversation that is about
religion in the lone just in like that
Christian community but there's like
this talk about like like I went to this
church it's a really popular church
everybody go every [ __ ] celebrity goes
there right and then one person asked
this pastor and he goes so what is the
what is the Protestant or Christian
stance on homosexuality right
I miss was very straightforward answer
whether people like it or not in that
faith it's like it's a sin that's what
he should have said if he is a pastor
and that's what he believes but because
he was so scared of losing people in the
church and not getting money in my
personal opinion he was like well let's
just say we have a lot of homosexual
people that come to this church and the
guy asked him again he goes that's not
what I asked I asked you what is like
the stance and he goes I he goes on you
wouldn't say it so he was worried more
about his person he
was about his religion whether that's
right or wrong I think like if you are
the leader of that church you should
just speak up for whatever you believe
in whether you're right or wrong yeah he
probably was to hold on to that power
exactly and so I was like oh that's kind
of weak dude you know I was like that's
kind of stupid I went to a private
school and then always just sing hymns
every day and that was my favorite part
of the class dude actually it's fun yeah
because I was on that list too music so
being able to sing hymns I'm like yes to
be a rock star
you're a [ __ ] praising the Lord yeah
man I missed the potlucks dude did you
do that at your church the small
churches after church there's always a
potluck do always food every week see
that's the difference between Protestant
and Catholic oh you guys didn't have
that [ __ ] ah I really didn't grow up in
church to be good oh my mom she would
she was she would cook for the church to
like every other Sunday it was so
[ __ ] good too we had every chore
every time oh Thanksgiving Christmas New
Year's special food we've got my Korean
ribs are you holding in your spit I went
to Korean Church and food is the awesome
big thing yeah even for Friday prays
nights if no one made food they would go
out and buy like 300 cheeseburgers
McDonald's oh wow everyone got one under
Slayer on the table and sometimes two
there would be the item app that takes
over the food stuff and I don't know is
the item I don't like because the food
sucks
oh yeah
[Music]